As a couple, we travel around in a van,...
...trying to make the world a better place with books.
I'm Alexa Trembly.
My name is Emory Harkins.
We act as a community's bookstore for a day where they don't have bookstores.
On a typical Saturday, we sell 25 books.
Being together, traveling to a new location every day,...
...we're able to get a different perspective,...
...just understand someone else's situation.
We chose diversity in publishing.
Women are being represented,...
...people with different backgrounds...
...such as being in the army or having mental illness.
We want all those stories represented.
It's fun to see the kids come up to the van.
First, they're excited about the van,...
...then they realize there's books there.
It's important to have kids start reading at such a young age.
It brings opportunities.
Books unlock different worlds.